[Music]
when I started I just you know I bought
20 sheets of plywood and just started
cutting I don't know how to build a boat
so it was a good design for me because
it was basically two shapes one is a
sphere one is a cylinder and just put
them together but tsunami ball is a 22
foot long a tanned 1/2 feet tall 10 feet
wide survival boat made of plywood and
epoxy he could put 1012 people in there
got the idea for working on the tsunami
ball I was I was in a startup incubator
in Silicon Valley and in one week we had
a presentation by an astronaut talking
about how asteroids might hit the planet
we should divert them or they caused
giant tsunamis and then two days later
that Japanese tsunami hit I spent a year
in Fukushima of course you imagined the
people that you know and the friends
that you had and you wonder if they're
okay it was a it was a hard thing the
idea is to design something that will be
comfortable on land so that if you lived
in a place that had tsunamis it would
just be in your backyard and when you'd
hear the alarm and the family would
climbed in and you'd be okay so it'll
sit in our backyard somewhere and it's
possible we'll try and do an Airbnb deal
where folks can come and check it out
and spend the night
I don't know what I've spent so far I
kind of look at it as I'm taking my
retirement early while I have the
ability to jump up and down and lift
heavy objects I've been at some fairly
successful startups which is also helped
with the budget for the boat the biggest
one was PayPal and at some point I was
at Facebook but what it's really done is
it's it's allowed me to think very
creatively about the problem solving
there are people who are making spheres
tsunami balls in Japan that are very
cost effective that didn't exist when I
started the project but this is I think
this is more like an art project than a
business